And now it's time to play
Talk Birdy To Me.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow.
Talking to animals isn't just
for your jade-wearing aunt
who has a pet psychic business
on the side.
I think anyone can do it.
So comedians, I'm gonna show you
a video of a chatty animal and
for 250 points, please tell me
what they are saying.
First up, this howling husky.
(howling)
(bell dings)
Chelsea.
Where are my balls?!
That... Absolutely.
Sean.
Why do seals keep trying
to (bleep) me?
Points.
Next up, this pissed-off puss.
(moaning)
(bell dings)
Oh, my God, I should watch these
before we do the show--
they're (bleep) terrifying.
What in the holy living (bleep)?
Jesus Christ.
What sort of weird
Egyptian mummy's curse
(bleep) that out on the...
the material plane?
Oh, I don't feel good.
Chelsea.
Why am I made
entirely out of taint?
-Jesus Christ.
-Points.
Sean.
She's clearly saying,
"Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, you didn't."
All right. Points.
What, did you just
get cheated on?
I got this pussy waxed for you.
And you cheat on me?
It's like...
All right, next up,
this pathetic panda.
(whimpering)
(bell dings)
Sweet perm.
Adam.
Where do you
want me to (bleep)?
Points.
Uh, Sean.
Uh, make sure
to try the orange chicken.
-That's what it's saying.
-Great.
Points.
All right.
(applause)
More points.
All right, next up,
this pig with the munchies.
(squealing)
-(bell dings)
-Uh... Sean.
Sorry, I'm being
a real me right now.
Oh, nice. It's, like, yeah,
it's coming back around.